jurors were selected today for Paul
Manafort scrim '''l trial in the Eastern
District of Virginia Manafort is in deep
trouble and though he has not been
convicted of anything he's already being
punished severely a large group of FBI
agents all of them armed stormed into
his home earlier this year
apparently surprising his wife in the
shower terrifying his family they could
have made a simple call to his lawyer
but they didn't Manafort then had his
bail revoked in an unusual penalty that
is for a 68 year old man with no
criminal convictions he has been held in
solitary confinement pretty much ever
since for 23 hours a day for the crimes
he's accused of in the state of Virginia
Manafort now faces three hundred and
five years in prison that's several life
sentences so what exactly is Paul
Manafort accused of doing if you guess
murder guess again most murderers don't
get treated like that by the government
the average violent felon in this
country receives just six and a half
years behind bars no Paul Manafort is
accused of something far worse than
murder tax evasion and violating banking
regulations the government isn't even
suggesting that Manafort stole money
from a bank they're saying he was
dishonest on loan applications for that
solitary confinement and 305 years in
prison
well if you're confused maybe this will
clear up the story for you the
prosecutor leading the case against Paul
Manafort is named Andrew Weissman he's
an enthusiastic Democratic partisan he
was a guest at Hillary Clinton's
election night party in New York now
he's trying to send Donald Trump's
campaign manager to prison for life on a
tax charge for perspective on that
the average sentence for tax fraud in
this country is a year and three months
it could be much longer though if you
have the wrong politics
apparently Alan Dershowitz is a retired
Harvard Law School professor the author
of the case against impeaching Trump he
joins us tonight
professor I'm gonna make the the obvious
disclaimer I don't know Paul Manafort
I'm certainly not gonna vouch for his
ethics but looking at this pretty
carefully this is a case about tax
evasion and bank fraud and he's getting
a sentence or he's threatened with a
sentence that is so disproportionate
compared to the average that it makes
you wonder Lee what is going on here
well it's very simple his crime is being
associated with Donald Trump and
listen to me on this listen to judge
Ellis the judge is presiding over the
case the judge ruled and said they're
not interested in mana for Muller is not
nearest in mana for they're just trying
to get him convicted so they can squeeze
him and if you squeeze a witness not
only does the witness sing but sometimes
according to the judge the witness
composes that is he becomes creative he
makes up information he elaborates
because they know the better the story
the better the deal so this trial today
is not about mana for DIF mana for
hadn't been associated with the Trump
campaign he'd be out in New York or
wherever doing his business it's an
attempt to convict him of whatever they
can possibly find against them no matter
how unrelated it is to the MOA probe in
order to squeeze him and get him to sing
and maybe even compose well how is that
different from what the Mafia does do
what I want or I'll take your life away
that's not justice as I thought it was
practiced in this country at all well
unfortunately it is the way justice has
been practiced against the Mafia and
against terrorists and we civil
libertarians have long been opposed to
this way of dealing with problems but
the civil libertarians are quiet today
why because the object is Donald Trump
do you hear the a cou complaining about
this do you hear the National
Association of criminal defense lawyers
complaining about this do you hear other
Democrats civil libertarians complaining
about this no we've always complained
about this tactic when it's used against
other people but now you have some
zealots standing in front of the
courthouse with signs saying lock him up
lock him up
you know I was objecting when they had
signs saying lock her up lock her up
relating to Hillary Clinton because I'd
be making the same argument if Hillary
Clinton had been elected president and
it was the Republicans who are trying to
squeeze somebody to go after her and
civil libertarians all over the country
ought to be concerned about this but
instead like everybody else they're
taking sides if this hurts Trump it's
good if it helps Trump it's no good the
Republicans take the opposite point of
view it's not good it's not good for
justice it's not good for civil
liberties
well especially when an actual human
being a 68 year old man is facing life
in prison for not filling out the bank
forms correctly it's pretty unbelievable
professor thank you for your perspective
um thank you